he at times appeared to work miracles at
one point I I was trying to test him and
his abilities and I recall that there
was a box that my grandfather had given
me that you opened with a little silver
key that had been lost for years and
years and he I said well if you can do
anything
why don't you produce the key that to
that ball which neither of us had seen
even the box for a dozen years by this
time he was naked and locked in a room
for the mission and and he went in he
would make these bizarre gestures the
extrange archit I don't know what was
going on and he he went into a period of
concentration gave a wild squawk and
slammed into my hand and gave me the key
gave me the key who was naked he had
been lost in this room for 14 days at
that time and I was like I didn't know
what was going on but what was happening
to me was I was like utterly unconcerned
for his mental health or any practical
concern which was causing a lot of
problems for the other people on the
expedition in classical psychology this
is called a date a ballet I do at the
illusion of - it's a simultaneous
Hispanic episode that usually involves a
mother and a daughter I've never heard
of a brother brother
haleh I do but it was accompanied by all
these exterior manifestations freak
rainbows and in my case an encounter
with a UFO and this UFO encounters had a
very curious quality to it not that they
don't always
but this was even more curious than the
pedestrian UFO encounter what happened
was it was on the fort it was on the
13th day as the reversal and that I had
had this intimation there was something
going on about the Southwest I wasn't
clear quite what it was and the two
women on the expedition were that
afternoon washing our clothes down by
the choro by the lake and I looked
across the lake and I saw in the sky not
a rainbow but just a spot in the sky
that was a spectral dramatic diffraction
you know a little patch of rainbow and I
asked the women if they thought and they
said they didn't and then it intensified
and by this time I was plenty in the
doghouse as well I mean this put a great
deal of strain on our small party as you
can imagine and this Spectre dramatic
yura duel intensified and then I said to
them now do you see it and they looked
and they said oh yeah mm it's in a big
deal not much but I knew I knew and
knowing means the voice was speaking to
me all kinds of weird things went on I
mean I discovered that I said the closer
I was to water the easier it was for me
to rhyme and which I never and then
years later I encountered a Celtic
saying poetry is made at the edge of
running water and and the thing would
give me the faster ISM like one time it
said the Clones
load is a stoned mode and you know and I
was not sleeping I was now 11 days
without sleep so that night I decided to
sit by the choro and just because I
stayed up all night and I would walk in
the fields and the
thing would draw the would connect up
the constellations for me and show me
where they were in the sky there was
also embedded in all this things the
intimation of this thing called the
teacher which was a giant insect-like
thing that was always like right over
here and there was the sense of
something watching us from the sky
something moving us very very gently but
persistently towards this very weird
breakthrough
[Music]
you
[Music]